what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel where i react to
videos and i really just research like
whatever i find interesting so today i'm
going to be talking about wrapper beef
so i started researching this because i
react to rap music on my channel and i
kept seeing rapper after rapper involved
in beef that oftentimes would lead to
people losing their lives over what
seems like you know something small from
the outside looking in so today i
decided to research a beef that is going
on now the beef that i'm going to look
into today is little dirk and memo 600
little duck and memo 600 they were like
childhood friends besties one would say
best friends pals memo 600 got signed to
the otf label and i didn't really see
like why this was a big deal like who
cares if someone gets signed to your
same label i found out that lil dirk i
guess owns otf and so i'm thinking how
did this man get signed if it's your
record label but i guess it was um lil
dirk's brother and he was like okay this
rapper's really good i'm gonna sign him
and little dirk didn't really have a say
in it which is confusing because it's
your label but whatever i again i didn't
even see why this was a problem memo 600
is like trying really hard at his music
so now i guess memo 600 isn't getting
the attention that he thought he would
or like the resources from the label
memo 600 was like riding for dirt he
didn't feel like lil dirk was like
riding for them i get it you know
sometimes you feel like you're putting
more into the friendship than that
person it doesn't mean you end it guys
you can work through it with some
communication you know what i mean memo
600 he gets shot now this was a super
close call he got shot like three times
barely survives and the crazy thing is
no one knows who shot him and it's
interesting because when i listen to
these rap songs like everyone listen to
the songs where they name names of
people they shot i'm like do the police
listen to this stuff do did i hear this
but who who am i to say right there is a
guy named tt benz said it was oblok now
personally i don't know who oblok is i
google this who is oblock it's the most
dangerous block in chicago um
it looks like it's maybe a section of
chicago where they just i don't know
maybe it's like a gang associated with
that part of chicago i don't know but
okay i guess you know moving on he gets
out of the hospital he's back and he's
better he's ready to make music his life
going in the right direction but then a
man loses a chain now i didn't think
this was a big deal i've lost stuff
before but i guess this was a special
chain it was very sentimental and it was
a gift from lil dirk now i get this i've
had i've had my mom give me a pandora
ring once and i i lost it and i felt bad
because i loved that ring my mom didn't
disown me for it but i guess the chain
was a gift from lil durk and i think it
says otf and that's for the label and
only special rappers get the chain so
it's really exciting for him yeah so
they did they rob him but so now this
guy named tt benz has this chain this is
the same guy that said oh block did the
shooting and i don't know if tt benz is
like part of oblock or how he knows this
information but i guess he does tt benz
is a disser so he's on live
dissing talking mad [ __ ] i'm for sale
ain't giving that [ __ ] back
where are you giving that [ __ ] back you
cannot get that [ __ ] back [ __ ] to
you know we got this [ __ ] oh we gonna
pass this little [ __ ] around and he
says they caught him lacking now i had
to google what lacking meant so in
chicago hacking means walking around
without a gun or it says someone unaware
not paying attention now i didn't think
this was a big deal if i got robbed my
friends might say hmm you shouldn't have
been in that situation if i put myself
in that situation but they wouldn't stop
being friends with me because i got
robbed it's not like you need to get raw
so little memo goes online he says i did
26 shows this year okay i'll buy 15
shane so you say i have money and then
he says y'all ain't gangsters y'all
thieves hashtag snitch k it's one thing
to get caught lacking but for an m
effort to set you up it's some pure
snake [ __ ] especially an mfr with your
same bloodline so brother because
brother did it they'll do anything for
some clout i see the same mfer that was
just on his trying to get down and it
shows you they only love you when it's
beneficial so now okay little dirt is
mad because now he's in the news for a
chain he's getting mocked oh what you're
thinking oh no not mocked that's bad
little dirk said how he gained they took
his chain and this is a dis
little derek is saying look it you were
careless my friend not anymore ex-friend
on nothing to do with you he's kicked
off the label so now i guess they're
basically like sub tweeting at each
other memo 600 says never in my life
been a follower or ben and no fanship i
respect guys that prosper that is all is
that is that a sneak diss i guess he's
saying like the other guys are followers
maybe that's that's the diss little dirk
then says nothing or nobody is
guaranteed in life in that tweet he's
saying i'm not friends with this guy not
homies not friends then little dirk also
said i hate when the ones you love down
talk you to look good for a couple
tweets and get a couple likes get you
some money little ones so he's saying
while you're doing this i'm making money
so then then memo 600 he's got to say
something back allegedly right so then
he says half these guys are worried
about what the next guy thinks of them i
think all of you guys are police so sam
why do you guys care what other people
think don't worry about it then he raps
talking this on property i'm gonna show
you the clip you guys can decide if you
think it's about little dirk maybe maybe
not
stop it all with bosses i'll be down
these [ __ ] burn my own property
and all i've done is one time pull up
here
so the latest news is that memo 600
signed to whack 100. now of course he's
got assigned to a new label right
why would little dirk be mad six nine is
also assigned to the same label so six
nine has dis little dirk so now lil dirk
is mad
at memo 600 has signed i believe that's
the latest update in the beef so from an
outsider's point of view this all seems
silly and small and not worth creating
this much drama and losing a friendship
over um a necklace but let me know in
the comments why you guys think this is
such a big deal and let me know what you
guys do you think it's a big deal or no
don't forget to subscribe for real if
you've watched three of my videos and
you have not subscribed we have beef
beef people hit that subscribe button
and i will talk to you guys next time